[Music]
one of them is my friend megan kelly who
joins us now from new york she's kicking
off a new podcast
uh of course she's not with fox these
days she was there for about 13 years
did five presidential debates
has interviewed every who's who on the
international stage
in the last 15 or 20 years a
world-renowned journalist but also just
a great lady hey megan how are you
hey dave i'm great how are you it's an
honor to have you thanks for hanging out
with us today for a little bit
so here is all mine so a new podcast
way to go how fun is this you know what
this is the place to be for me
because i'll tell you having worked for
a brief stint at abc
13 and a half at fox and then another
brief stint at nbc
i have realized number one i'm no good
with bosses
i i can't be working for a boss anymore
dave it hasn't worked out so well
and number two i just need to go
someplace where i can say what i want to
say
i'm like like a lot of americans i'm
just i'm sick of being told what i can
and cannot say
think be do so i love the idea of just
going to this alternate universe where
i i can say whatever the heck i want to
say you know you don't like it you don't
have to listen you like it stay with me
yeah that's the reason the dave ramsey
show is the largest syndicated
talk radio show in america that's not
corporate owned i own it
it's called the dave ramsey show and so
i get to say what i want to say because
i freaking own it and if you don't want
to listen you can go somewhere else i've
been saying that for 20 years
it's fun you're going to like it well
honestly
and to your point of like when i was
coming up with you know what i wanted to
do and how it would look
i had a lot of offers for investments
right like i'll
i'll pay for the whole thing as long as
i can have this percentage and in the
end i was like you know what screw it
i'm doing it myself i'm gonna
self-fund this thing we'll start small
we'll build from there if we do well
but i want to own it because i don't
want anyone
telling me what i what i can and can i
say i've had too many years of that
and it's just it's not the wave of the
future especially now with the total
collapse of media
yeah yeah and they just are falling all
over themselves
the um but what's interesting i mean
you've already put a couple of episodes
in the can and so
um see if you've had this experience
what's interesting is
is the um the percentage of what you
wanted to say that you
did that you were told not to say or
told to say or something like that
it's very small it's just aggravating
yes we're going to get like 99 percent
of megyn kelly we already know
that's absolutely right but the thing is
like political bias
pushes you one way or another when
you're in what you know they call legacy
media now right and that's true at fox
and it's definitely true at
the other networks even more so i would
say fox was the most open-minded to
letting me say what i wanted to say
within certain
sounds and then the pressure is enormous
elsewhere to
to be you know one way or another and i
try to resist it as best i could but
at those big networks you only have so
much control over the final product
because it's like working for a
newspaper the editors get their hands on
it and then
it's no longer your product so i'm i'm
sick of that but more than that
you know our country's getting to this
weird place where you can't discuss
sensitive issues openly and freely it's
basically just
agree with my point of view or you're
terrible right and your cancer
you're terrible and i'm gonna cancel you
yeah you're a big at your you're
transported you're xenophobe you're
sexist you're all the phobes
and stop talking and that that's just no
way forward we have to be able to talk
about
everything it's un-american to be
stifling people and now you're getting
the people you know around dinner
parties starting to whisper their
thoughts to you and i'm thinking to
myself what is this east germany why
don't you just like
speak up and now more than ever people
do need to speak
up because i think we're being we're
sick of being shamed into submission
on things that are dicey and complicated
and require complex thought
and idea exchanges well the interesting
thing is when you actually can have a
discussion
without screaming or yelling with
someone that has a brain
that disagrees with you you end up
learning something
but when you completely yeah when you
completely do away with that what was
the phrase that was a good phrase
shamed into submission yeah silence and
submission because
you know what's happening is first sort
of the mob wants to silence you
then they want to that you to submit
right to sort of bow
and then what really happens is you need
to join them
it's not actually not enough just to be
neutral now you need to here's the
problem
i was i was just preparing a talk i'm
giving this week and this morning
yesterday afternoon and the problem is
even if you acquiesce even if you go
along with all of it
there's one little tiny sliver that they
still get pissed off about you can't
make these people happy
absolutely right there's it's funny
because this one woman who works in one
of my doctor's offices
she is a lesbian she's got the tattoo
she's got the piercings she marches
against trump every other weekend
she's very woke fairly woke and she was
on some website
and yeah i used a term like she
guessing about somebody and she started
to get shamed how do you know it's a she
how dare you presume the pronoun
and she basically looked at this group
and she was like look
i do enough
i'm totally woke leave me alone but
there is no amount of wokeness for the
woke
that's right i was just sick of it it's
like come on you're a good human being
just
get off of it the least jagged at least
generous lens used on every human being
and it's just not the way we are we
actually have real problems we need to
be focused on not this nonsense
so the new podcast the megan kelly show
and i assume you've got it on all the
platforms i do
and if you're anything like my mom not
you dave but any of your listeners
um you gotta go to the app the app store
on uh on apple type in podcasts
and then just download that button and
then once you've got the podcast button
on your phone you type in
megyn kelly and i'll come up that's
simple my mom's like i don't even know
what that is a podcast how do i even get
that on my phone
i'm like mom i will send you an iphone
with a little button already on
yeah well she once she gets addicted
though she'll be on i mean
my wife is podcast fanatic and never
listens to me of course but she's a
podcast fanatic
yeah so yeah it's totally catchy
yeah it's really really a big deal very
cool so you got our friend ben shapiro
on one of the first episodes i see
and he's one of the reasons i'm doing
this i know ben
well and and have been friends with him
for a long time i was actually one of
the first people to put him on tv on the
kelly file
and people were like this guy he talks
really fast and he's really incendiary
and he's really young and i was like
shut up he's a star
and he's so good he's so smart so smart
he actually is the smartest guy in the
room you know how most people think they
are
yeah he really is and he's so smart he's
not even self-deprecating about it he's
like yeah i am i know i am
but anyway so he called me up about a
year
a year ago and he was like listen mk i
don't know what you're doing next but
consider this podcast world and i didn't
really know much about it i
at that point i'd only been listening to
like dateline which i highly recommend
by the way
just falling asleep to the sounds of
murder is very soothing
um but he was telling me how it could be
made into a viable business
for news and kind of walk me through it
and i went out there i met with him and
his partner jeremy boring his
business partner and uh they helped me a
lot so they're one of the reasons i'm
into this now
yeah met in the cigar room with the dog
that's right yeah been in been in that
room myself yeah
but that room's gone he's my neighbor
now he and jeremy are moving to
nashville
you know and who could blame them
they're having the same situation in la
that i'm having on the upper west side
of manhattan
yeah not what it used to be you think
yeah uh yeah so they yeah they got out
of california and are setting up shop
here as our neighbors i've been in touch
with them and
we're friends as well so i'm excited to
have you
for you to have him as one of your first
guests and then the second uh
is with hugh hewitt huh hugh hewitt came
on to talk about the presidential debate
last week and we had
glenn greenwald who is he's a lefty but
he's
unconventional like you don't you never
know where he's coming at things from
uh dropped an episode with ted cruz but
i just dropped one yesterday or no sorry
today
with adam carolla which i have to say i
absolutely love i
i hope people go listen to this because
it's all about cancel culture
and adam is like a savant on that stuff
and he made that movie no safe spaces
guy knows what he's talking about well
worth a listen megan we're proud for you
be praying for your new show the megan
kelly show where great podcasts are
found
good luck and god's blessings thanks
dave right back at you